друзі сьогодні розповім вам про чергове
варення російської пропаганди означає вони
але це роблять ну і взагалі
поширює цю історію що як вони
переможного відступають, а українці їх
боягузливо наздоганяють взагалі до того щоб
довести власне кажучи про те, що
відбувається реально вже не просто говоримо
на відміну від них полювати з фактами мені
ми залізли в мережу вконтакті заборонену
мережу та подивилися що там відбувається
тоді багато цікавого зараз розповімо
вам докладніше ви підписуйтесь на канал
щоб нічого не пропустіть відео та
стримувані і з місця подій тут дуже
багато важливого і потрібного тому тут
вам місце і тут на вас чекають так що ми
маємо у нас якщо заглянути до ну ви
знаєте що ще розповісти що у них
втрат немає та інше немає але якщо ви
підете в контактному суцільні некрологи
некрологи та некрологи просто величезне
кількість але вже відоме відео
тільки про десантників подивіться його
натана алея пацанів
цвинтарі будуть Михайлів
всі шляховики пацани
втрат у збройних силах Росії не
далеко ви бачите втрат немає але тільки у
одному регіоні десант як мухи мре та його
ховають пачками так що загалом
цікаво звичайно втрат ні ми розуміємо
самі звичайно що це повна брехня і ось
це відео тому доказ ну а ось
якщо проаналізувати некрологи те що
ви самі побачимо по-перше ми самі бачимо
вікову цікаву штуку дуже багато
молодих загинуло і це говорить про те, що
вони такі відправляють терміновиків просто
як м'ясо гинути на цій війні вже там
навіть пишуть як 19 років, що там 19 років міг
поїхати guy хто там себе
нічого не вміє проти армії які
воюють 8 років, яка захищає свою землю
мотивовано та й результат
відповідний не це потрібно щоб
розуміли російські матері дружини сестри
тому що насправді чекає цих пацанів
тут тільки смерть і тому і добре
видно по контакту ще цікаво
географія ці там якось майже немає
москвичів та петербуржців
все там глибина якась далека їх
відправляють помирати все-таки москвичів
мабуть побоюються або вони там
відкупляються я не знаю що відбувається але
ось москвичів та петербуржців дуже мало
багато
глибинці
багато північного кавказу загалом ось
звідти вони черпають цей ресурс та друзі
кого ще дуже багато це звичайно наших
луганська та донецька так званих лнр і
ДНР
там взагалі повна труба вигрібають усіх
поспіль ось послухайте там одна жінка
яка говорить про дистанційне
освіті послухайте що вона каже
де там чоловіків осі голови донецької
республіки
це указ про відновлення навчального
процесу дистанційного навчального
процесу
не питання до цього довбоящер
попросив усіх передплатників моїх
поширити обереги поширюєте
куди тільки можна я просто читаєш мені
питання до цього довбоєбу мабуть били
сильно
18-річних
директно силявки 9 ніхто не те ви
зміните у мене мало що я спати рости 18 і
19 літніх студентів каді мобілізувати
вчителів або сильно [ __ ] або і
мобілізувати сука сніг мусе тому що
ніхто не хоче йти воювати за справу що
республіку розумієте ніхто не хоче на
ви вирішили ось так от не зрозуміти і будемо
розігрівати всіх
нього
дуже хоче розповісти йому кибальник
режим все чоловіків не залишилося вигребли
всіх-всіх кинули на війну і
підтвердження цьому є інші відео
ось по суті, що кажуть чоловіки про те
хто вони і звідки і штанці роблю ми ми
військовослужбовців Донбас звичайні роботяги
бляти діти на
етики [ __ ] заводчани бляти
нас напали на ми на сумах [ __ ]
є до youtube та відео де наших
товаришів взяли в полон
загинуло дуже багато
таким чином просто ріжка набрала всіх
жителів ЛНР і ДНР і як м'ясо і hanowa
чому по-перше в цьому є логіка цієї
імперії як такої це імперія
вона захоплює території для того
щоб захопити людей і кидає їх у бій
для того, щоб далі захопити
наступних людей наступної території але
ось дивіться їх логіка вони
підкорили чечню, яка довго билася
за билася відчайдушно але не її дотиснули
масою що називається закидали після
цього вони 20 років промивають нам мізки
людям вона навіть сир але не дуже
виходить мені масу листів із чечні як
вони ненавидять кадирова і росію
якусь частину означає вони таки
перетворили на лаборантів потім вони цих
кому якісь ніхто містик так війська на
якусь частину справді кидають із
кавказу з дагестану північної осетії
збирають їх означає і кинули їх наступну
війну на природі 36 ом році на ту ж
грузію
фактичні анексували до південної мережі
абхазію тепер звідти збирають осетин of
з південної осетії абхазів і кидають їх на
наступну війну, а саме крим і донецьк
луганськ а зараз вони кримчан хто в
перших рядах був у них кримська морська
піхота що вони кидали їх щоб вони
воювали проти українців та повністю
вигрібають весь людський ресурс
чоловічий ресурс донецька та луганська для
щоб кинути проти України тобто
про промивали їм сім років вісім там
мізки тепер означає кинули їх вмирати
ідея така чому він так важливий
україна є величезний людський ресурс
ідея була така захопити Україну далі
тут спробувати мізки кинути українців
далі вже на балтика на польщу
дуже класична російська радянська
імперія і вони цим шляхом і рухається
у цьому і був власне кажучи їхній план
тому так і активно не використовує лднр
ну і друге це звичайно
і важливо це з пропагандистської точки
зору що забрали у вас
чоловіка відправили залишається там одна там
до сім'ї і вони розповідають як у
проклятий українці його вбивають щоб
збудити ненависть у них, а проти своїх
ж співгромадян українців із великої україни
скажімо так у цьому їх ціль ну а потім
далі роблять картинки коли ті
повертаються багато хто не повертається хто
повертається часто без руки ноги він би
стоїте на це відео де там один із цих
ополченців
мобілізований без ніг залишився та каже
йдіть йдіть за новоросію світ від
послухайте
виконуйте завдання навіть незважаючи на те саме
завдання на якихось жертв набираючи
але й руки
але у мене забрала але не було товару і
якого теж ми не засмутилися
духом не впали ми всі чітко мазані лайки
ну і що може зробити кожен із вас як
україна може цим працювати та
контрпропаганда українці у цьому сенсі
теж молодці як і у всіх інших
знаходять ці групи у тих військових
торгували в буча ірпінь інків сто миль та
російських правильно сказати вбивали там
і
значить у результаті
показують їм фотографії того, що вони
там наробили і це дуже звичайно
також ось теж креатив виявляють знайшли
таку групу вже душечки військова частина
46 108
значить це дівчата які чекають на своїх
хлопців із цієї військової частини ось вони за
рахунок зібрали чекати їх там разом з
зробили групу ну а наші туди кидають
фотографії полонених частини цих хлопців
або загиблих їх ну і що чекали-чекали ну
як же душечки дочекалися як ви
розумієте це теж у цьому ефект
бомби, що розірвалася так що друзі
креатив ведемо війну на інформаційному
фронті це дуже важливо я для вас тільки
що це все зараз розібрав
тому не вкотре не забувайте
підписуватися та ділитися цим відео
кожен ваш лайк шер передплата то ваш
внесок у нашу війну в нашу перемогу на
російський військовий корабель ви знаєте куди
йому йти всім привіт із Києва